(ストラップ：こんにちは　はじめしゃちょーです)
(ストラップ：ｷﾞﾔｱｱｧｱｧｧｧｱｱｱｧｧｧｧ)
こんにちは　はじめしゃちょーです
〜が終わりましたあああ
ありがとうございます　ありがとうございます
いやいやそんなめっそうもない　めっそうもない
いやいやそんな大層なことはしておりません
あのぉとある罰ゲームでギリースーツを1週間着なきゃいけなくなったんですけれども
まぁちゃんと理由付けをしてやろうと思いまして
まぁ罰ゲームと言いつつもギリースーツ1週間着ると
色々わかることがあるのではないかと思いました
そもそも夏場に着るギリースーツの暑さはどんなものなのだろうか
そもそも姿を隠すためのギリースーツを日常的に着るとどれくらいバレなくなるのか
あの僕街とか歩くと結構なんやかんや
あの声かけていただけるんで
これ着ると意外と声かけられないんじゃねぇーかな
みんなには見えないんじゃねぇーかなと思ったりしております
しておりました
というわけでえーっと、1週間
肌身離さず、寝るときとお風呂入る時以外は基本的に
常にギリースーツを着たまま1週間生活してみました
それではご覧ください　どうそ
おはようございます
ギリー2日目です
雨も吸収するんですよね　ギリースーツって
(だいち？：実質何万〜〜何百万？)
はじめ：300万
(だいち？：300万割る25は)
ちょっちょっちょ　おーあぶねーあぶねー
轢かれるとこだった
｢はじめしゃちょーやー｣って言われてる
(だいち？：近くに居る側からすると)
はじめ：うん
はじめ：あー
(だいち？：気づいてないからかもしんないけど)
はじめ：あっそうか居ないことに慣れ始めたってこと
悪くないねぇー
ありがとうございます
けんすけ(後輩)：はははは　やかましいｗｗ
はい、というわけでいかがだったでしょうか
暑い
一応なんかメッシュみたいになってるんですけども
それでも超暑いんすよ
あとギリースーツを着てない時より着てた時の方が
ざけんじゃねぇー
【はじめしゃちょーエンディング】